[Música]
vamos ahora con revistas de prensa en
directo américa para ello ya está
conmigo en el estudio de rosa pérez más
de euros a bienvenida a buen día y feliz
jueves para ti vamos a hablar con una
noticia en desarrollo con la que
iniciamos nuestro programa directo
américa y es la situación en líbano que
pasa en líbano vamos a ver entonces dos
periódicos el primero va a ser al yazira
al menos seis muertos y varios heridos
por disparos dentro de una protesta rosa
buenos días raúl exactamente pues está
en desarrollo todavía se van conociendo
más y más detalles de lo que está
pasando en estos momentos en las calles
de beirut pero pues nos fijamos en lo
que lleva ahora mismo al yazira una
noticia desarrollado por su corresponsal
en líbano karim ya jeff que pues nos
cuenta un poco la crónica de la
situación de esta manifestación
convocada por hezbollah para revocar
pues al juez de instrucción que está
investigando las responsabilidades en la
explosión recordemos a de agosto de 2020
en el puerto de beirut donde murieron
unas 200 personas y más de seis mil
resultaron heridas pues bueno también
pues los período escriben lo que quieren
destacar y en este caso pues recoge el
testigo el corresponsal de al yazira de
un joven que perdió a su padre en esta
explosión y que aún así pues al lamenta
la manifestación contra el juez dice no
entiendo por qué protestan contra
alguien que está buscando a los
responsables de esta catástrofe en lugar
de protestar contra el gobierno contra
la clase política porque recordemos
ahora mismo el país líbano entero está
sumido en una crisis económica
energética política no y esto es lo que
quiere destacar un poco este
corresponsal política y social además
rosa yo le agrego a ella le gustó le
estaba diciendo vamos ahora con otro
enfoque vamos con él lo guían leyó
escenas de guerra en el corazón de
beirut eso es este a medio francófono
basado en el líbano pues también hace
una crónica con sus periodistas sobre el
terreno de lo que está sucediendo y
alzan la cifra de heridos hasta los 20
según sus fuentes en distintos
hospitales y bueno destacan que lo que
está sucediendo ahora mismo no en el
seno del gobierno
libanés que es de ella
inestable es que pues los políticos
chiítas pues vinculados a esta esfera de
hezbollah están pidiendo que el gobierno
se posicione no respecto a la revocación
del juez ya que de momento el presidente
y el primer ministro lo están apoyando
no pues se pide que el gobierno se
posicione y pues amenazan según este
medio de una dimisión en masa de bloque
chiita del gobierno lo que podría llevar
el país de nuevo una nueva crisis
gubernamental una información en
desarrollo o rosa por supuesto muy
pendiente de lo que ocurre en beirut
para informarle a todos ustedes nuestros
hoteles brillantes y continuamos con más
de revista de prensa ahora con otro tema
nos venimos a américa del sur
específicamente a chile porque ya
ocurren dos cosas rosa primero la
situación con los mapuches y segundo
pues lo que va a pasar con el clima
inestabilidad política por la
destitución al presidente que quieren
iniciar el presidente sebastián piñera
pero vamos a comenzar con la tercera
hablando de los mapuches dice long con
califica de preocupante la instauración
del estado emergencia en la macro zona
sur y dice que la medida no en palmas
con la historia que nosotros necesitamos
exactamente raúl y a pesar de que piñera
según recoge este artículo y como hemos
venido comentando cuando declaró este
estado de excepción pues insistió en que
no era contra ningún pueblo en
particular sino contra el crimen
organizado pues evidentemente esto se
enmarca no dentro de este conflicto
histórico chileno por la reivindicación
del pueblo mapuche de estas tierras
ancestrales y pues elisa loncón la
presidenta de la asamblea constitucional
chilena pues ella misma también mapuche
dice que esta situación es preocupante
para su pueblo y aquí pues unas
declaraciones suyas lo que la ciudadanía
necesita aquí son soluciones políticas
en función de la cultura para llevar
adelante los procesos económicos que
permitan superar la pobreza de las
comunidades
vamos a ver entonces rosa con el
mercurio también hablando del segundo
tema que pues estábamos adelantando dice
gobierno advierte de clima de
inestabilidad ante la acusación de
intentar destituir al presidente piñera
rosa exacto nos fijamos aquí en la
edición del mercurio que un detalle de
formato es bien particular esto qué
digital es la misma que la edición en
papel simplemente pues en una página web
y bueno vemos que deja de lado esta
cuestión del conflicto mapuche y pues él
se centra en esta advertencia del
gobierno de sebastián piñera por lo que
comentaba en los noticieros está
potencial destitución este juicio
político por su aparición en los pandora
papers por este conflicto de intereses
no con la venta de acciones del proyecto
minero dominga ahora rozamos con un tema
pues es que me gusta me apasiona además
es impresionante la avanzábamos en
nuestro sumario al principio del
programa el 'times square' bajo el agua
el zócalo en llamas así afectará al
cambio climático a sus calles esta es
una portada del país en su edición
américa exacto está además el formato de
estas noticias bien interesante es una
noticia que está esto en la puerta del
país américa de manuel pasqual y que
pues destaca el proyecto de un grupo de
científicos del instituto de
inteligencia artificial de quebec que ha
creado un proyecto que se llama este
clima no existe this clima de desdén y
crisis lo podemos ver en un link que
está directamente en el artículo o
entrar directamente en la página y lo
que han hecho como estamos viendo aquí
en estas infografías que reproduce el
país es que uno puede entrar su
dirección la dirección que quiera en
este en este portal y le dan tres
opciones ver cómo esta imagen por
ejemplo uno entra a su calle y puede ver
como su calle estaría se vería si
estuviera afectada por un incendio por
una inundación o por una nube de
polución entonces es una forma de
acercarnos a lo que puede ser nuestro
futuro puede ser próximo si pues no
logramos pues combatir con políticas
reales el cambio climático y esperemos
que esto sólo se quede en tecnología y
en esta elección pues esto es porque
mira aquí vemos el capitolio de
washington cómo podría quedar no
inundado pero aquí el zócalo de méxico
pues en un incendio o también abajo una
inundación
muchas cosas que pueden pasar rosa
esperemos que no ocurran gracias por
esta revista de prensa al día de hoy los
medios mañana con más vamos a orar con
nuestro primer invitado el día
[Música]